Don't worry, concentrate I'm helping you study for the test My
beloved sister is cold today too
If you don't want to hurt your grandfather's mood, at least you have to be in the top 100
I can't concentrate
Saying that kiss
That's why when you held my hand
[Music]
I thought you responded to my feelings
Wh You're still a college student,
why are you showing such facial expressions?
Please teach me so that even a fool like me can understand
Oh,
if you teach me the meaning of that kiss then I'll study properly
I don't know how to treat my name like this
There's no point in that. There's no way
we, sisters, can have a better relationship than
women do
.